khi ông Phát Biểu, hàng chục đại biểu các cuu gia đa rồi khỏi chung,
bất chấp lời kêu gọi chất tự bán tổ chất.
Sòng một sống người khác thì đứng dậy hoàn gai
bên ngoài chú sợ lên hợp của ở điều dọ,
hàng nghiên ngồi biểu tình, um họ plastine cũng tập chung, phản đối trên sự giải gà ra.
Bất chấp của trên giao dạ gần hai năm đã khiến hơn
sau mới lắm nghiệp với kênh mạng và nạn nói đã đưa ra sang nhật.
Ông đình đã cho gùo bác bỏ, cao bút dễ chung của toàn hiểu sức của tế
và tình bố isên ràn sẽ tiếp tục trên rịch.
Nhằm tư siet hoàn toàn được lượng à mắt,
ông cũng ở thông điệp đến các con tìm còn bị giám dữ,
hàng đình chính phủ sẽ không nừng lực để đưa họ chở về.
Chức là một ngày,
tổ thông vi đúng năng tròm cụ khẳng định,
Washington sẽ không cho phép isên ràn sắp nhập bởi tay,
với lĩnh đạo miếng cũng cho biết đàn tục đầy một tổ thật hoặc biệt 2 miếm mốt liếm,
nhằm chấm dịch trên sự tại giải gà ra.
Đông thời bảo đam cho giải pháp, hành nha nước.